- So, ihr Graffiti ist entfernt.
- Sehr schön gemacht, sehr gut!
- Die Fassade da oben, die Glasreinigung
ist auch fertig gemacht.
- Sehr schön.
- Dann müssen wir uns nur noch
den Teppich angucken.
So, der Fleck ist weg,
der Teppich sieht wie neu aus.
- Das ist sehr schön gemacht,
gefällt mir sehr gut.
- Das ist schön, freut mich.
Also, wir haben uns jetzt die ganzen
Positionen angeguckt,
Position eins: Graffitientfernung.
Position zwei: Fassadenreinigung.
Haben wir ja auch kontrolliert.
Glasreinigung haben wir ja
auch kontrolliert.
Teppichshampoonierung haben wir
jetzt auch kontrolliert.
Brauch ich noch bitte ein Autogramm.
- Ja natürlich.
- So, vielen Dank. Müssen wir noch einen
Termin vereinbaren wegen der Glasreinigung?
- Ja, ich denke 14.8.,
das ist ein Montag.
Wird es dann werden.
- Kein Problem, halten wir fest.
- Halten wir so fest.
Also vielen Dank.
- Alles klar, bis 14.8.!
- Danke, schönen Tag noch!
- Schönen Tag noch, tschüss!